okay hi guys uh we are here for the
banter blitz so let's uh
let's just start actually without any
unnecessary foreplay
i'm going to accept all the premium
challenges or well the ones that i'll
accept at least
and i will just start probably with
well i don't know with something let's
do
some five minutes challenge from
a person called hungry eo
okay excellent excellent i'm white here
so i'll go e4
e5 okay so far so good
i'm still in my prep it's called the
spanish opening
fighting for for the center
well the hungry angle is very well
prepared this is called the open spanish
because it is still spanish but it is
already open that's why it's called the
open spanish bishop e7 would be the
close punch
yeah it's very well prepared eagle
yeah so far it's all major theory there
are a lot of moves here bishop
e3 c3 knight d2 queen e2 and all kinds
of moves
let's play c3 it's a good
move the b3 bishop can always be tucked
into c2
and i guess somewhere around here my
opponent should start thinking because
otherwise he would be
way too well prepared for someone one
rated 1500
bishop c5 is okay i will just put my
queen somewhere prepare bishop e3 trades
of
the bishops
they told me that i could read chad but
well
i decided not to because it's not very
convenient
i have a small screen and i tried
minimizing all the windows and it was
not very easy
so unless you have something very
important to tell me
if you do to send an email to my website
or something like that
otherwise i'm not going to be reading
the chat
actually i might
just for fun yeah so what is
yeah you see the chat doesn't say
anything they say like wow wow
castle bishop e3 that's what i was
planning as i
promised i'm going to trade the bishops
and invade on the weekend dark squares
that's the plan in the open spanish
black instead has to move away his c6
knight and push his c pawn to c5
or break the sender with f7 f6 and open
their file
this is what he has to do but i'm not
sure that that's what he will do
27 is just a move
it's a normal move to connect his rooks
i'll develop my knight this
seems to be a very educational punter
blade session today
i'm explaining a lot about chess
and yeah i think many people love that
don't you don't you love it when
somebody explains your chest
isn't it what you are here for i don't
know why i have headphones
basically i have headphones to hear the
sound of the moves
because this is what calms me down
for some people it's the sound of the
ocean for me it's the sound
of chess moves and it's the habit i
acquired
1962 it's interesting i have lots of uh
things that i can capture
but um i'm just going to capture back
the knight with the queen
well my i don't know what to say really
here
um it really depends on how he's going
to play it if he will play it correctly
with some
some sort of a attempt to put pressure
on my center
that's going to be not so easy knight a5
is interesting
we can try to make a thematic game out
of this
so let's just play
some sort of a neutral move
like for kd1 maybe
the thing is that he can go bishop g4 at
some point and slightly annoys me
so i might go h3 make i hope he takes on
b3 because then i
got a good night against the bad bishop
potentially
you guys do you feel the knowledge
penetrating your brains here you feel
how i'm explaining the open spanish and
the
fight for the center and all the you
know
important important lessons of chess
he either should push the c pawn to c5
not immediately because i'll capture to
the queen but
knight c4 is an interesting attempt to
confuse me i will just capture the
knight
essentially i'm still fighting for those
dark squares
let me do it a very slow manner like
like that trade these pawns
and hope i will lock his queen side
dark squares and then once i have all
the squares locked i can establish
my knight on d4 which will support my e5
and
f pawn very well and then i'll just
crash through with
f4 f5 this is my master plan
let's see what chad says
oh gustafson gambit says i love that
giri talks about the actual games i've
seen many on banter blizbet
disinterested in their games
it is kind of ironic that i am reading
his
message because he would probably rather
have me focus on the game
yes a5 is uh excellent move
fighting as well for the photon squares
i don't know i'll
to be very honest with you i'm not
really
i haven't accomplished anything
too great in this in this game so far
the masterpiece has yet to be created
the work of art is
yet to reveal itself
well let's see let's uh i don't know
let's play knight d4 for now if c5 i can
take on e6 hours
originally planning to play queen c5 and
get my knight to d4 that would be
beautiful but
he suddenly has some second thoughts
about maybe f6 and bishop takes h3
somewhere and you don't want to get
bishop takes h3 against a hungry eagle
because that's the kind of food he is
waiting for
that's what the hungry eels eat they eat
those h3 ponds
how is a guy's how's the everything
going here
is the sound excellent is the picture
beautiful
tell me about it i will read it in the
chat okay see it he playing he plays uh
very well well maybe someone taught him
the open spanish and told him that
you've got to fight for the c5 square
and he just remembered that and now he's
executing
the knowledge that he learned like
before
open spanish is such a great opening
that even the difference of
1 400 points still not
very seen in this game although now i am
um definitely better because i've got
the knight on d4 undisturbed
and there is nothing he can show for
that except for the fact that he's got
um
well he traded lots of material so it's
all on one one wing but still
i'm sort of dominating the the position
here and he cannot break with c5 and now
he also has a time
issue which is a pity because i would
have really
loved to convert this position
it's a pleasure it's a pleasure to
convert a position like this
normally speaking unless you don't
convert it because then it's not a
pleasure at all
this is the funny thing actually about
pleasure
you know unfortunately is running out of
time it was five and a five minute game
i believe
or three minutes i don't remember was it
a five
i don't remember but yeah it's yeah
total time he played very well
credit to him he hasn't blundered any
material at all